cuffy petites communes du cher et point
zéro de la loire à vélo où vient de se
marier la loire et l'allier de la 800 km
cyclables permettent de rejoindre
l'océan à saint-brévin-les-pins l'idée
de créer un cheminement ligérien a vu le
jour en 1995
vingt ans plus tard 950 mille touristes
dont un tiers d'étrangers emprunte tous
les ans l'itinéraire de la loire à vélo
marion travail au comité régional du
tourisme centre val de loire
elle est en charge du développement de
la loire à vélo en fait la loire à vélo
ce n'est pas qu'un itinéraire cyclable
c'est vraiment une destination
touristique à part entière et on l'a
voulu comme tel en justement développant
des services adaptés à la pratique du
vélo en développant des réseaux
d'acteurs vraiment des hébergements
touristiques en premier lieu ensuite des
loueurs et réparateurs de vélos des
offices de tourisme des sites de visite
et de loisirs on peut également faire
d'autres activités et est couplé
justement le vélo avec des activités
plus nature
marion rend visite à christophe guide
naturaliste
il fait partie des cinq cent quarante
partenaires référencés qui enrichissent
le parcours de la loire à vélo
il partage sa passion pour les bec
d'allier en proposant descente de loire
et découverte de la flore et de la faune
voilà alors ça indices de présence
caractéristiques du castor donc là on
voit bien la branche qui a été sectionné
voilà ça c'est un crâne de castor on
voit bien ici
les instances incisive et puis on voit
aussi qu'il a la possibilité de
transporter très facilement c'est comme
une passe des morceaux de bois dans sa
gueule
c'est ça qu'on recherche l'interaction
vraiment on veut favoriser en fait ce
contact avec la population locale les
gens qui les professionnels vraiment
le long de la loire à vélo c'est
passionné de la loi parce qu'on en
rencontre beaucoup tu es passionné de la
loire comme comme christophe et nous
notre notre envie c'est ça c'est de
montrer aux touristes
vous avez toutes ces choses-là découvrir
mais ces gens là également qui vont vous
apprendre qu'ils vont vous montrer
qu'ils et puis rien qu'à écouter c'est
passionnant
le
et
voilà tout
la loire s'est pas uniquement des
kilomètres et pour la découvrir ce que
souvent ce qu'on conseille aux gens
c'est de la découvrir sur des petites
distances c'est pas en faisant 100 km
par jour on peut voilà après faut savoir
si on est venu manger des kilomètres ou
découvrir vraiment une région la loire à
vélo ne se limite pas à la seule
découverte du fleuve sur le site
internet dédié le patrimoine est
plurielle nature histoire architecture
culture arts de la table le site permet
de repérer choisir et organiser son
itinéraire nous sommes à bf tout proche
du bec d'allier la loire à vélo a permis
ici la promotion d'un patrimoine
culturel riche et pourtant peu connu
la municipalité pour accompagner ce
tourisme itinérant a décidé de bâtir des
hébergements une initiative qui
accompagne le comité régional de
tourisme
c'est vraiment un itinéraire accessible
à tous types de publics lille le à tous
les budgets
parce qu'on a vraiment tous types
d'hébergement également aussi bien
l'auberge de jeunesse de l'hébergement
collectif
hôtels chambres d'hôtes de charme
camping également donc vraiment tous
types d'hébergements avec tous types de
tarifs donc vraiment accessible à tous
et d'aucuns plus accessible qu on est
quand même sur un relief assez plat donc
c'est également accessibles de par sa
facilité le vélo et les modes
d'itinérance douce autorise plus
facilement l'observation l'arrêt et du
coup organisent plus facilement
découverte les rencontres
aujourd'hui devant l'engouement du
public l'offre s'est enrichie avec un
site dédié à la rando à vélo et même un
site européen qui pourrait bien vous
emmener jusqu'à la mer noire